go attacks The Rook
he went the long way around with that
Knight but now he's attacking Black's
Pawn you can even just give up
everything now capture that pawn and he
does so the King of Porn end game will
be winning for white
and uh we'll see that in action I'm so
happy the players are playing onto the
end here we'll learn a lot from this end
game but white essentially has a
passport this is the same exact porn
structure that Magnus Carlson and Wesley
so had in the queen end game actually
with Queens on the board but this one is
winning because Queens are off and
anishikiri he thought his opponent was
about to resign
no surrender and this F Pawn the
protective passport is going to win the
game for white black spawns are dropping
game over Anish will take the win
there it is he takes the lead in The
Blitz Ty breaks on each Geary with the
white pieces and Blitz game number one
yep he shows up five fingers five
minutes until game number two Anish in
the lead with a great win in the arena
in San Francisco